over the last month or so I've released
three feature-length reviews expressing
what exactly I love about Dragon Ball Z
in excruciating detail examining
everything from the thrilling Saiyan
Invasion the chilling Frieza Saga and
the massive but widely acclaimed Android
and cell arcs the latter of which acted
not only as the coronation of Gohan as
the Earth's new primary Defender but the
conclusion to a story that many widely
considered Akira toriyama's finest work
his Magnum Opus One that exposed the
complexities of this story its highs and
the subtle genius behind the mind that
helped to bring it all together and now
for his final Arc the culmination to
over a decade's worth of expertly
written manga where does Akira Toriyama
want to take us
ah faster than a speeding bullet
more powerful than a locomotive
tall buildings of a single bound the
infant of scripts on is now the Man of
Steel the great Saiyan man
[Music]
wait Gohan your lunch
sorry it's just that the Venn diagram of
Supply chains for prison and school
cafeterias is basically a circle thanks
Mom you're the best
sorry you have to travel 600 miles to
school it's all right I've got the
coolest ride in my grade
[Music]
later mom always listen to your teachers
and remember old women are liars and
you'll always be baby and you'll never
grow up Lincoln I go to school when your
father comes home
after what has been an exceptionally
long stretch of increasingly more severe
and serious stories told this small
Prelude to the upcoming material is
perhaps the most refreshing palette
cleanser the series has to offer and
while it does feel somewhat strange for
reasons I will absolutely get to later I
think it's clear that this is Akira
Toriyama at his most unbridled in a very
long time creating an arc that shares
more in common with the first Arc of
Dragon Ball than perhaps any other and
it is that very aspect of this Arc that
in my opinion makes it on a mega level
the single most fascinating introduction
any Dragon Ball Arc has to offer forcing
me to examine not just how the plot
functions but additionally why this path
was chosen at all for these characters
having been thrust through the exciting
Tenkaichi budokai's of Dragon Balls past
all the way through to the cell Saga
material there's been what has felt like
a gradual increase in Stakes emotional
or otherwise and yet here we are going
to school stepping in to stop
street-level crime hiding our secret
identities and exploring a budding cat
and mouse game slash romantic
relationship with Videl why this shift
in approach and atmosphere is so
dramatic so drastic so sudden it seems
impossible to consider that it came
about unconsciously and I don't think it
did it's almost like a soft reset for
the series consciously and structurally
distancing itself from what came so
naturally before and for me this
complicates things typically in these
reviews I write in a rather
straightforward or chronological manner
examining plot beats as they occur while
moving towards an obvious and compelling
goal it allows the videos to feel
nostalgic and affords me a built-in
structure from which to review the show
from thus allowing me more time to look
under the hood and for the most part
every Arc up until now has rather
quickly established their goals the 23rd
Tenkaichi Budokai begins and we know
that defeating Piccolo is the goal the
Saiyan Saga kicks off with Raditz and 3
through that we learn of Vegeta and Napa
almost every single Arc in the series
old and new assumes a similar structure
but this Arc stands out from the crowd
and in many respects I think the tonal
shift is perfect after the non-stop
Sprint from Raditz to sell we've just
endured for three arcs straight we've
finally been afforded the chance to just
enjoy a moment of Peace the very peace
we've so feverishly been fighting for
all of this time with these characters
and with these reintroductions to all
characters we get to explore brand new
ones in ways we haven't had a chance to
since the beginning of this story it's a
very Slice of Life enjoyable and Light
Affair however there is one element that
forces it to feel dramatically different
to even the comparatively light and fun
first Arc of Dragon Ball and that
difference is toriyama's choice of main
character
[Applause]
Son Gohan it should come as no surprise
to anyone that this story pivots in a
rather Goku way what begins as a
wholesome and Slice of Life tale of
Gohan navigating his responsibilities as
the Earth's hero in the big bad City
quickly switches gears to something far
more familiar once a certain tournament
is announced in the story and I'll even
acknowledge that when reading along this
might feel somewhat fine if not almost
unnoticeable however when your job is to
analyze stories like mine is you start
to notice a few things and what I
noticed was a pivot so seismic that it
dwarfs in my opinion every other pivot
observed in the prior Arc while the cell
Saga had to deal with course Corrections
simple changes to a plan that ultimately
led to the same goal that he had always
planned for this Arc sees Toriyama shift
the very foundations he spent so long
establishing and unfortunately there's
quite a lot of controversy surrounding
this creative choice so in the name of
objectivity I'll try to present the
available and limited information for
you first and foremost before offering
my own two cents on the matter later I
the four of this new material following
the seven year time skip on chapter 421
Akira Toriyama addresses his readers on
the title page saying Dragon Ball will
continue for just a tad longer from now
on taking the place of the late Goku as
the main character will be his
serious-minded son Son Gohan looking at
this it's clear that Akira Toriyama
wanted everyone to know from the outset
that Gohan was taking Goku's place he
even seems to be on some level excited
as another quote taken from the very
issue of Shonen Jump this was released
within says at last the story has begun
with Gohan as the main character even I
the author I'm looking forward to seeing
what will happen given the fitting and
emotional exit Goku was offered as a
character it seems reasonable to
conclude that this was a fresh start in
many respects for the series
opportunities are bound to go in
interesting new directions free of the
familiar and into a bold New Direction
and this sudden shift is evidenced even
further through the anime opting to
leave behind the longtime iconic Chala
headshallah theme song in favor of the
new we gotta power musical track and
this was a shift in musical open that
hadn't been seen since the transition of
Dragon Ball to Dragon Ball Z in the
anime however with the benefit of
hindsight we can tell that this Vision
if you could even call it that didn't
last many have speculated as to the
reasoning why however the only
explanation offered by Akira Toriyama
has been and I quote I intended to put
Gohan into the leading role it didn't
work out I felt that compared to Goku he
was ultimately not suited for the part
and so that's it he wasn't suited to the
role people have offered their own
speculations as to why is it in Gohan's
popularity or lack thereof as one of
many possible explanations forcing
Toriyama to yield his vision to appease
than outcry however I don't think this
was the case so why do I think Akira
Toriyama pivoted well I think it
involves something far more mechanical
and foundational within the story's
narrative itself at numerous instances
throughout this Arc but mostly Within
These early chapters there are gags that
otherwise wouldn't fit in the more
serious Dragon Ball Z material but can
find footing here Gohan literally looks
into the camera and talks to the readers
directly breaking the fourth wall for
the sake of a joke and that
light-hearted atmosphere is all over
this area of the story and truth be told
I actually loved reading through this
section there are heaps of fun character
interactions a fish out of water
storyline with Gohan trying to fit in at
school and of course a very enjoyable
Dynamic established between Gohan and
Videl
between putting out fires in downtown
narrowly saving hundreds from a
potential plane crash and stopping bank
robbers single-handedly Satan City and
maybe Earth itself has found a new hero
and that hero's name is the great Saiyan
man oh my God is the part of his name
what is he a rapper it is a weird name
for a superhero I think it's kind of
cool of course you do you're hell folks
sharpener iratsa he knows I love him go
on you know I love you I guess he's a
menace a superhuman wannabe hero
enforcing his Justice on my city unlike
you who enforces your Justice on your
dad City I'm Different he's working
outside of the law I work with the
police oh and that makes you the good
guy what does that mean it means you're
my favorite nepo baby Videl and I love
you however I don't think this is what
makes this Arc feel different none of
this is emblematic of whatever
ultimately pushed Toriyama into a
different direction but I think I know
what is you see Dragon Ball has worked a
very specific way with high energy
characters exacting their agency upon
the plot moving it Forward characters
like Goku and Vegeta fit this building
they can react to things certainly but
they also Drive the plot forward through
their own internal desires through their
own active decisions Goku by
consistently seeking out stronger and
stronger opponents and Vegeta through
wanting to prove to himself and to
others that he's the most powerful in
existence due to the desires of these
two characters quite a few exciting
story beats found their footing in this
long and winding tale that without them
wouldn't have been as exciting and
that's what makes these characters come
telling to follow simply put they make
the plot happen when they are on screen
you know we are going to be advancing
the plot and not marinating in the
current circumstances waiting around for
someone else to act however it should be
emphasized that this does not mean that
active characters are better suited to
the main character role over reactive
ones it depends entirely on the genre
and context of the story that you're
trying to tell Spider-Man as well as
many other superhero films that have met
great critical Acclaim are obvious
examples of stories with main characters
that are oftentimes more reactive than
active and it works exceptionally well
for those stories and this is clear not
just in this Arc but even in all the
material that came before it Gohan is a
character that requires support from
others a cause that can ignite a fire
within him to fight with that aspect of
his character is the reason the ending
of the prior are concluded in the
fashion It ultimately did and is the
reason so many people love Gohan Gohan
offers the power and ability all the
world Goku and Vegeta provide the
support of his tremendous power required
and look you're not going to catch me
calling Gohan a boring butt plug of a
character that could put an insomniac to
sleep that's Dragon Ball Super's Gohan
however I suspect it's not a character
type Toriyama himself is comfortable
writing for up until now Akira Toriyama
has spent his entire life writing
dialogue and stories for easily
excitable and energetic characters that
take the narrative by the horns and I
think on this occasion Akira Toriyama
found himself in a situation he didn't
foresee having an issue with but
unfortunately unlike arale unlike Son
Goku Gohan is one of the most reactive
characters I've ever come across in the
very first chapter of this art Gohan
reacts to the robbers he reacts to being
seen he reacts to being beckoned into
the classroom he needs to be told to
introduce himself to take an empty seat
he doesn't even choose for himself where
to sit even when it comes to talking to
other characters in school he very
rarely strikes up conversations
remaining demure are usually requiring
others to take the initiative in
conversation where Goku was unabashedly
able to be himself throughout the entire
series eventually pushing himself to a
point where he could be super saiyan at
all times without even trying not caring
about what way he looked go on in a
contrasting fashion is forced by others
to quite literally use his Super Saiyan
transformation as a mechanism to hide
who he truly is he's not a Super Saiyan
warrior like his father it's simply a
mask he wears to afford him the
opportunity to do what he feels is right
and honestly that's one of the most
genius visual ideas offered in this Arc
I think perhaps even in the entire
Series this is why I suspect Gohan's
schoolmates erase her sharpener and
Fidel are all confident and outgoing
characters who speak their respective
Minds freely this is kind of a tangent
but there's a frankly absurdly funny
baseball scene in this early School
portion too Gohan plays baseball for
what he says is the first time in his
life and hilarious Antics ensue no less
and fittingly all of the comedy seems to
stem not from Gohan but sharpner's Brash
and boisterous personality meeting the
wall that is son Gohan's athletic
ability naturally he wouldn't be able to
react this way if it weren't for sun
Gohan but yeah I just thought it worth
mentioning but of those three characters
that Gohan goes to school with the Dell
is by far the most assertive in other
words within this introductory portion
of the Ark Videl is the active character
which not only helps to smooth over the
pacing but it makes her Dynamic with
Gohan exceptionally fun to watch and
forces us as readers and viewers to see
them as two entities that complement
each other exceptionally well where her
father is a fraud posing as the grand
protector who saved the world from cell
right under her nose is literally the
one responsible for cells to fees and
more than that just like his Good Deeds
stopping those thugs suggests he
actively avoids any and all credit for
these performances all for the exact
same reasons he never entertains the
idea of stopping in the first place
because he's a good person and feels
that this is his responsibility not
something he deserves prays for but
something that he should and ought to do
wow look at you Krillin you've got hair
and the proof I had sex hello oh what's
your name
so are we gonna talk about that or talk
about what it's my grandmother's name
about how great it is you can still have
children no thank you you're welcome
goodbye
you're right it is funnier if we act
like I don't know it's old Jeff
the strongest in the heavens Returns
what Gohan has presented to Toriyama
with unforeseen challenges thanks to his
passive nature Fidel represents
toriyama's attempted answer to that
problem creating a perfect compliment to
Son Gohan and let me tell you she's a
pretty good answer all things considered
and because of her Toriyama very nearly
succeeds in making this early story work
because she's one of the most well
conceived of characters from both a
personality and mechanical perspective
remember when I said that Gohan was a
protector well Videl is an instigator in
every sense of the word she chases
Gohan's Alter Ego forces him to act when
he otherwise wouldn't discovers his
identity through her own investigation
and is the literal force behind the
Tenkaichi budakai being reintroduced to
the story black meaning Gohan into
joining without Fidel there is no
tournament and there is no return of
Goku and so in a sense she not only
exists as a perfect compliment to Gohan
but a perfect compliment to this very
Story by virtue of Simply existing
within the story she makes Gohan a far
more interesting and compelling
character and interestingly Gohan in
turn makes her that much more
interesting too a key element of Adele's
identity is that she's the champion of
Earth's daughter The Offspring of a
larger than life character that casts a
shadow so vast he steals the focus in
pretty much every scene he participates
within because of this she has grown up
in his shadow often not treated with the
respect she so sorely deserves as a
fighter and as a result unbeknownst to
both her and her father she has long
since surpassed him by a considerable
margin though unfortunately no one
around her can see it that is until
Gohan steps into her life Videl is the
only one at school that sees Gohan for
who he is and conversely Gohan is the
only one who sees her for who she is and
it's that inverted Dynamic that makes
these two so interesting for Gohan with
his father Goku was literally said that
he was better suited to this role than
he was in other words were videl's
father steals the spotlight from her
Gohan's father relinquished that very
Spotlight willingly to someone he was
happy was better than him where Vidal is
seeking out the respect and
acknowledgment of others Gohan quite
literally and specifically tries to
avoid it at all costs nothing happens
randomly in the story apart from that
fish and videl's challenge put forth to
Gohan is no different and it's made in
the back of her discovery that Gohan is
the son of a former world champion in a
sense Gohan represents two Videl the
opportunity for her to step out of her
father's Shadow and in a way for Gohan
this agreement to participate in the
tournament and train with Videl allows
him to retain his secret identity it's
an air-perfect Dynamic that I would have
loved to have seen explored further had
the story gone a different direction
then great say a man what's your story
I'm just a small town boy with alien
blood looking to make a difference you
an agent of just
just standing up this
[Music]
from me
just killed your mom well no uh I
actually lost her to The Big C but that
backstory doesn't exactly strike fear
into the hearts of criminals yeah I lost
my dad to The Big C too oh wow I'm so
sorry
Cancer's a [__] huh oh no I thought you
meant cell but didn't everyone
mysteriously come back after he died not
everyone
did you say alien who wants to learn how
to fly
in the meantime however while Gohan is
still at the Forefront Toriyama takes
this as an opportunity to start steering
the story back into a realm he feels
more comfortable writing material he
very specifically excels at and that
material is training arcs of course by
arcs I mean a few chapters but man are
they an absolute blast to go through
starting with some of the one-on-one
training with Goten these really serve
as our actual introduction to the new
member of the sun family somehow an even
more carefree and childlike version of
Goku their entire training evokes strong
memories of Goku training for the very
first time with Krillin and roshi the
actual training they undergo has that
exact same type of approach as well no
complicated techniques are Kung Fu
mantras just a very simple and concrete
idea Dodge the rocks and once again
Goten proves how Goku like he is by
completely exceeding Gohan's
expectations punching literal holes
through the mountain as the ark
progresses Goten and Trunks as well end
up playing increasingly pivotal roles in
the events to come and they are both
introduced in very similar ways as the
spitting image of their father at least
in terms of character the training with
Vidal that focuses on key is equally
simplistic and fun to the point of
influencing multiple generations to sit
in front of their TV and try their best
to channel some key along with Gohan's
instruction no it's okay you don't have
to lie I did it too we all did but again
it just speaks to how good Akira
Toriyama is at this fundamental training
business even something as mundane as
learning to fly a move that has become
completely ubiquitous for the past
several hundred chapters is distilled to
its core and presented in a way that is
just so enthralling to view and read and
the whole ordeal only deepens a
relationship with bedel as well as Gohan
so you're this massively powerful half
human half alien super Warrior God I
mean seeing that about myself feels a
little conceited but what I'm saying is
you can dodge bullets much less any
attack I throw at you well
yeah honestly
why do you ask
no reason
the 25th Tenkaichi Budokai there's a
small moment right after Goku arrives at
the tournament grounds where he notices
how big everything concerning the
Tenkaichi Budokai has become having been
to the considerably more modest 21st
through to the 23rd Tenkaichi budokai's
the latter of which he won he can see
how much more ostentatious everything is
now he even acknowledges the ring itself
is bigger leaving Piccolo to quip that
while the ring is indeed bigger the soul
of the place has gotten smaller this all
seems rather innocuous and really if
you're breathing through the material
this moment is easy to glance over as it
doesn't manifest in anything later on
however I think it really says a lot
about the headspace Toriyama was in
while writing what he'd likely plan to
be his very last Arc I spent a lot of
time talking about how Gohan was
eventually shifted out of the main
character position by Akira Toriyama and
many might reasonably conclude that that
shift began once Goku returned but I
genuinely didn't feel that to be the
case while I was reading this when Goku
returns at the Tenkaichi budakai it's
presented as absolutely special but it
also represents something else the
passage of time the old and the new in
other words Goku or previous main
character feels more like a cameo than a
returning character and moments before
Goku makes this triumphant return from
the dead and reunites with his friends
and family Mr Satan makes his presence
felt too uproarious Applause and
adulation he marches away feeding into
the crowd and so too do the chorus of
his fans follow along in the manga we
can see the Fanfare and crowd dissipate
Over the Horizon before Goku a true hero
of earth makes it comparatively much
more modest return to quote Akira
toriyama's narration during the cell
Saga the world had forgotten Son Goku
character as of yet instead
interestingly he represents what was and
Mr Satan represents what is and moreover
this Dynamic he offers the story speaks
to what is undoubtedly the central theme
of this Arc fostering the Next
Generation and ensuring the Earth has a
bright future ahead of it both after
Goku as well as after Toriyama puts an
end to this tale and speaking of the
future it's time for the prelim
qualifying rounds of the
okay I guess it's time for the junior
division then
[Music]
Goten vs trunks
it is crazy that outside of the random
run-ins with criminals and some loose
training sequences this is the first
proper fight in the arc 13 full chapters
or over three months of real-time pass
by to get to this point but honestly I
think it's worth the wait because what
we got was brilliant it's still very
light-hearted but with the added rivalry
of Goku and Vegeta watching their kids
for the very first time it's a wonderful
proxy to add even more tension to the
occasion it's sort of like watching the
two old main characters Pokemon battle
each other with their own children
however the fight itself is plenty
enjoyable from an artistic standpoint I
think my favorite aspect of it can be
seen in its General messaging with the
conclusion to the fight itself and with
this in mind I think it's my favorite
fight in the tournament the general
message of the fight I think is that for
children the guidance of those they look
up to is more important than anyone
might realize now I do have my reasons
for thinking this to be the message of
the fight itself the first time we hear
about Vegeta in this Arc is in the
context of training his son Trunks and
the first piece of dialogue he utters is
directed towards Son Gohan Gohan
um
this might seem callous or at the very
least out of pocket to a regular person
but coming from Vegeta offering advice
off the back of training voluntarily
with his own son it might be subtle but
it's clear that the themes and lessons
of the previous Arc have had their
impact on him the old Vegeta wouldn't
have ever dreamed of spending time with
his son let alone training with him the
old Vegeta wouldn't have offered advice
to others unless he stood to benefit in
some capacity in this Arc he's an
entirely different person and all of
that is communicated in the very first
scene he contributes to Furthermore with
regards to Goten from the moment he
walks out in the Juniors division all
the way up to the conclusion of this
final with trunks I love how the
youngest of the sun family is
characterized it's a total contrast to
that which Gohan was introduced to the
story with while Gohan was made to be
the exact opposite of his father in
almost every Dimension as I outlined in
the prior arcs I think there's strong
evidence to support the theory that
Goten shares a remarkable amount in
common with his father
childish incredibly naive sheltered and
picks up on techniques and abilities
remarkably fast techniques like flying
Super Saiyan and the Kamehameha most of
his Arsenal he's learned either from his
mom or his older brother that he looks
up to a ton and while toriyama's panel
flow is as strong as ever boasting more
fantastic layouts and posing the ending
to this fight is by far the most
interesting aspect of it trunks the more
experience of the two in an effort to
prove his superiority over Goten in
front of his father offers to not use in
addition to Super Saiyan his left arm
but Goten uses this as a chance to prove
to trunks that he's more than he ever
gave him credit for
[Music]
did in his first tournament Goten fails
to pick up the victory with his age
being the Difference Maker that cost him
against the older trunks this is a great
way for Goten to lose as a character not
losing face due to the scrappy nature of
the Finish but what I love about it
actually has nothing to do with Goten
but instead Vegeta The Wager trunks made
with Goten right here to not use one of
his arms mirrors almost exactly the very
wager that his own father made with him
in the gravity chamber it's a wholesome
moment and one that speaks to how much
trunks looks up to and wants to be like
his father further emphasizing how
different Vegeta is and how much better
off trunks is as a child with him in his
life without Vegeta Trunks might not
have won
[Music]
guess that's what I should expect from
the son of kakuma
okay how about we get a little spicier
oh hey Gohan you taught him on a Dodge
pull it up
[Applause]
wait does that mean we can use of course
we can't duh
[Music]
saying it right right
wait even if you say it wrong it still
works then why did we say it at all
because it sounds cool does it though oh
come on he knows I love him you know I
love you D great Sandman seriously
though who put that durag on him and
then of course Toriyama can't help but
interject some more funny into the
tournament even at its first climax
[Music]
German feels exceptionally strange and
that's not to say that every other
tournament before this felt the same or
similar by any means they all gave us
unique reasons to hang on every page
turn whether it be any of the Tenkaichi
budokai's from early Dragon Ball the
Cell Games or even Baba's tournament
there's always been a narrative through
Lane that was established before those
outings in other words they all had a
goal whether that be roshi to stop Goku
from winning the Rivalry between the
crane school and Roshi's crew the threat
of Piccolo Jr the fate of the earth
friends or more there's always been
something to latch onto that sets a
particular tournament apart from the
others however curiously with regards to
this tournament what sets it apart from
all of the others is that it doesn't
seem to have a clear goal right now I
suppose there's the stipulation of Gohan
trying to hide his secret identity from
Videl but at this point that seems
rather I don't know secondary and of
course there is a somewhat interesting
sense of Adele trying to make a name for
herself away from her father but those
two feel incidental or rather secondary
than what would normally be present and
instead of this goal this Arc seems to
be almost acting as a celebration of
Dragon Ball instead having fun with all
of its characters new and old as they
engage in hijinks that is until the plot
suddenly shows up and slaps us all to
attention
to add further strange fuel to this
already frankly strange tournament fire
the lots that are drawn present us with
one of the most highly anticipated
rematches in the series history Goku vs
Vegeta in the opening round and
seemingly unresolved rivalry now offered
its chance for resolution much to Vegeta
and Goku's respective Delights but again
this is strange normally tournaments are
structured such that there's a clearer
path to follow to the finals for the two
focused characters starting at the
prelims they make their way to the
quarterfinals and eventually semi-finals
before arriving at the end of their path
at the climax facing off against one
another but instead fittingly Toriyama
decided to flip the structure on its
head in the process throwing any and all
expectations we might have regarding
this tournament out the window which
would be a disaster structurally if he
had any intention of seeing this
competition through to the very end in
the first place
cancel
huh
okay when I first saw this I was
legitimately taken by surprise however
now looking back at it I think it's
likely Toriyama getting his act together
because this is the moment where the
plot finally starts to pick up and
what's more is a villain makes his
presence felt Shin's placement in this
story as of right now feels somewhat
familiar to the role in which Kami
occupied in the 23rd Tenkaichi Budokai a
being that has descended from on high to
right or wrong he feels a responsibility
concerning and whether this is a
familiar choice or not I am thrilled
that now this story has a more focused
Direction and funnily enough there are
interviews where Toriyama himself was
talking about this part of the story and
confessed that he eventually felt that
he should stop goofing around and
introduce a bad guy or something and he
does just that
the Dell vs spokovic
as I've said before Videl is a character
that's defined by her agency within the
plot itself her ability to strive for
her own goals and instigate events in
the plot to help her push towards those
goals very much make her who she is
presently early on she was one of the
only reasons the story had any conflict
whatsoever with her seeking to carve out
her own place in history as a respected
fighter and not simply her father's
daughter she's very capable perceptive
and intelligent picking up on Clues and
outsmarting Gohan on a number of
occasions so far however in this scene
in this fight with spokovic that active
quality which defined her character is
taken from her as the narrative passes
through this moment in the tournament so
too does the story begin to pass over
Videl more and more ultimately changing
her function within it it's a point
where the truth is revealed to her and
ostensibly it's revealed how little
control over anything she actually has
this is where the story truly Begins for
this Arc but it's also where Videl
begins to lose her Spotlight as stronger
foes are introduced her place in the
story begins to wane a shift that
continues all the way through to the end
of this story and well into Dragon Ball
super where she is well the let's just
say there's a reason I didn't mention
her a single time in my multi-hour
review of Dragon Ball super for now
though this fight acts as the last stand
for Videl the result of her headstrong
blunt nature crashing head first against
a foe and really a plot that she doesn't
stand a chance to beat despite being the
daughter of a fraud she has faced every
challenge in her life so far with
absolute determination and that very
determination is what pushed her to
overcome all that has stood in her way
facing off against situations that would
put her in League with the Dragon Ball
crew at the beginning of the series she
has been yet another Bastion of hard
work overcomes all so much so that even
Goku who just moments be
interested insane Satan fight goes out
of his way to to check in on videls she
may not be on their level but she has
clearly worked hard enough to Garner
Goku's interest and that says a lot but
unfortunately sometimes there are walls
that are too high to climb not her own
undying determination not her legitimate
strength not even the otherworldly
techniques that Gohan the savior of
Earth taught her can protect her and
help her through this moment and with no
prior experience with defeat she faces
the consequence of that wall in a truly
brutal and painful way it's a tough read
in the manga and even tougher to watch
in the anime
you know
online the series 73 we've ever
witnessed oh come on this could be way
worse she still has all of vital organs
I have to do something I can't let this
continue
if you step in you'll be disqualified
damn it you're right
[Music]
within the story this sudden Beatdown of
Adele is a massive total shift and this
is noticed even by the likes of Goku and
Krillin when asked if they have sensus
for Videl Krillin simply says that they
don't because they came here to have fun
and with this abrupt yet violent shift
in atmosphere along with it a terror
begins to permeate each individual page
a sense of unease begins to build as we
experience this dark mystery unfold with
Gohan now being used as a live Base by
the Supreme Kai allowing him to be
ambushed by yamu and spokovic and that's
when I noticed it a change not just an
atmosphere but in story Dynamic Gohan
isn't the main focus or main character
any longer at least not on his own
anyway during this most recent segment
of the story we've been reunited with
and followed none other than Goku's
point of view once again backstage as he
watches the madness unfold around him
much like the fight between Goku and
Android 19. in this fight similarly the
intro Creek isn't Gohan vs kabito in a
sense but instead the reactions of
others surrounding the action and
controversy that unfolds mostly seeing
through the perspective of Goku as he
asks questions we want answers to
ourselves from the likes of Piccolo and
even Shin it feels like we're back on
the same page as Goku and while Gohan
certainly hasn't fallen tremendously far
or anything like that he's no longer the
sole point of view and his dynamic in
the story is about to change even more
now sharing the top spot with his father
who alongside shin and Vegeta find
himself tailing spuppovic and yamu on
route to the main threat of this Arc
babadi dabra and the sleeping monster
they hope to wake up
yeah
trying to catch up to Goku and the
others on their way to Bobby's Hideout
Videl and Gohan are seen traveling with
kabito but Videl is visibly
uncomfortable and struggling this is
entirely logically consistent within the
story itself however it does seem
strange to have this moment virtually
right after having her decide for
herself to travel with Gohan in the
first place over the course of two pages
Fidel decides to dip admit she can't
match up to Gohan figures out that he
was the kid who defeated Cell along with
his friends and that her dad was a liar
all of that emotional storytelling
material that may or may not have been
considered for a storyline in the past
in the blink of an eye was
unceremoniously unloaded on us and to me
it really felt as though Toriyama was
like oh yeah oh yeah I did have all that
baggage to unload on that story that
went absolutely nowhere
oh well time to dump it here I guess LOL
one chapter ago she asked to come along
and now she's going back surely this
should have been a conversation before
they left though I suppose this is to be
somewhat expected this is probably the
most significant change in Direction the
Story has ever seen and I'm talking
about the full Dragon Ball story when I
say this when pivots have happened in
the past we've had to sit back and wait
momentarily while Toriyama found his
footing again times like 10 shinhan
going to check on choutsu during the
lead up to sell was particularly funny
and so I guess now Toriyama in a similar
fashion is trying to get all of his
ducks in a row for what will undoubtedly
be an ambitious villain reveal made
possible through a horrifyingly
treacherous Gauntlet according to the
Supreme Kai as he Goku and all the
others watch silently and unseen from
the surrounding mountains
consistent with toriyama's other villain
and antagonistic reveals dabra and
babidi's intro is very solid hidden away
in Rocky outcrops Our Heroes look on and
assess the situation while babidi and
his minions accept yamu and spokovic's
harvested energy Toriyama likes to
implement funny naming schemes for
characters he lumps together for the
Saiyans they are all named after
vegetables for frieza's forces they are
things you'd find in a fridge such as
cheese milk and various fruits and for
Bobby it's no different with his
namesake his father's an even Majin
Buu's himself stemming from a musical
track found in the 1950 Walt Disney film
Cinderella entitled Bibbidi Bobbidi Boo
similarly dabra Pui Pui and yakan are
names derived from popular magical
phrases dabra from Abracadabra of course
while we is from Chinchin Pui Pui a sort
of Japanese magical good luck charm this
later adapted his name to Pocus from
Hocus Pocus is to give English viewers
an easier time the icon however wasn't
changed at all and is well less obvious
it's likely stemming from a popular
1960s anime with the magical incantation
being
takumaku mayakone don't ask me I'm Irish
not Japanese I do however find it funny
that spokovic and yamu didn't enjoy this
same naming convention perhaps Toriyama
saw it unnecessary to name them this way
or more likely Toriyama had yet to
decide which villain would show up and
therefore gave them more natural
sounding names and this speaks to the
idea that this whole second half of the
story was really an impromptu decision
but it's not like it matters much anyway
because as soon as they fulfilled their
purpose babadi demonstrates his cruelty
first hand and moreover his
short-sightedness a trait that becomes
important in his characterization later
on using his Wicked magic he stretches
Popovich From the Inside Out ingrown
test contortions before he explodes
while pokus sees to a fleeing yamu in
distress unsettling as it is casual and
perhaps most unnerving they know they're
being watched
[Applause]
bobbity's Gauntlet this Gauntlet that
challenges Our Heroes against these
magic monsters is a fun idea one that
establishes a clear structure and goal
for either side of the conflict to enjoy
for babidi he needs to steal their
energy through combat in order to
resurrect his Majin Buu and for the
heroes this is their chance to quell
This Disaster before it gets the chance
to take hold but there's something else
that further complicates this story that
genuinely makes it compelling for me the
Revival of Majin Buu doesn't come about
because of one simple mistake or a lack
of ability necessarily but instead a
series of similarly consistent decisions
consciously made by all fighters
involved which allowed babadi every
chance he had to harvest the requisite
energy from our heroes had Goku and
Vegeta not being there boo might not
have revived had Gohan hated the advice
of Vegeta and others before and trained
consistently perhaps all of what
ultimately takes place from this point
on could have been avoided and while the
Heroes of the story have been lured into
the proverbial Lion's Den to take on a
gauntlet of unknown Oddities from the
moment this first fight begins Toriyama
proves that the lion that threatens this
Mission doesn't simply dwell within the
ship it doesn't stand across the stage
from them either and it cannot be
punched instead the true Lion in this
Den can be found within each individual
hero a conflict inside each of these
characters that has yet to be resolved
characters that on paper should have no
problem achieving this goal and yet
because of who they are their history or
their nature our heroes are about to set
in motion an avoidable disaster the
likes of which will challenge them in
ways never before seen Vegeta vs Pocus
this is yet another one of those Vegeta
fights from the anime that gets a lot of
play because it is one of the few Vegeta
matchups that doesn't have a caveat to
it in other words this is a Beatdown of
the highest order one that during its
brief stint Shin starts to realize the
scope of the heroes he's aligned himself
with Heroes he dramatically
underestimated which he'll proved to
regret later on Vegeta vs Pocus is again
massively entertaining but would you
believe much shorter than even the short
bout the anime boasted when Bobby
transports the room to Planet Zune for
the benefit of Pocus only for him to
reveal that it's 10 times Earth's normal
gravity there's a wonderful effect
created for us as an audience dramatic
irony is a powerful tool and in the
moment we along with the Saiyans know
something Pocus shin and babidi don't
that he's totally outclassed in every
conceivable metric
doorster
[Music]
Vegeta didn't even need to go Super
Saiyan and that only speaks to the
dramatic level indifference between what
Bobby has at his disposal versus what
the Earth casually has to offer right
now there's a neat line from dabra
during this sequence where he remarks
that the Earth didn't have Fighters like
this when he last checked them 300 years
ago and I love that time frame because
it means the last time he checked it was
right before roshi took root and
established the martial arts that would
eventually blossom into what we see in
the story today it was a wonderful
little throwback for me Bobby and dabra
might have looked imposing and shin
might have painted a devastating picture
but strangely the message communicated
to us Here and Now isn't that a fear but
instead as we move down to the next
stage of this Gauntlet we're overcome
with this bizarre sense that we're
massively over prepared for this
encounter almost like this Gauntlet is
really just here to let our heroes strut
their stuff and if that fight with
Vegeta just planted that thought in
their heads then the next brings it
exploding to the Forefront of our minds
[Music]
many of you will know of or may even
contribute to my patreon at this point
up until now it's mostly just being a
way for you guys to directly support me
of your own volition but now for the
first time ever it is evolving we are
completely overhauling it not only is it
a great way to help the channel but you
will now be able to gain access to a
wide variety of awesome exclusive perks
we've got amazing wallpapers for PC and
mobile based on the great artwork I've
had made for the channel over the years
and these now come with time lapses of
their creation too alongside this you'll
gain access to not only uncensored
versions of the videos but you'll be
able to watch in progress previews as
soon as they're finished during the week
no more waiting for YouTube but a big
part of this is really about connecting
with you guys and ensuring the most
passion of you have your voices heard
we'll be taking video suggestions from
you guys as well as producing an
exclusive q a video every single month
and of course it wouldn't be complete
without a series of my incredibly
embarrassing outtakes that my crew sure
love to laugh at every single week
examining her newly acquired pit
so please head over to my patreon Linked
In the description and see what tiers
work best for you and either way your
contribution will now result in your
name featured at the end of your videos
as a way to recognize you and say thanks
this channel wouldn't be possible
without you guys and I hope this patreon
serves as a great place to support one
another with these awesome rewards I
can't wait for you guys to see some of
them
foreign
[Music]
following the emphatic and frankly
embarrassing defeat of focus at the
hands of Vegeta we switched to Bobby's
perspective only to discover the once
overconfident and Below Hardy warlock is
starting to feel an unfamiliar sense of
shock and Desperation resorting to his
strongest fighter save dabra in a
monster called yakan one that even dabra
anticipates will devour and leave
nothing left of her Heroes behind and so
before this fight with Goku and yakon
even commences we can see that the
villains are starting to feel a little
hot under the collar but that was with
Vegeta and with Goku they don't even
know the half of it again offering every
Advantage possible to Yacon from his
home field all the way to removing
Goku's ability to see babidi thinks he
secured Buu's Resurrection with this
Ploy however all he's actually done is
offer Goku another stage upon which he
can display the level of Competency he
possesses as a fighter first in a
similar fashion to that of Vegeta Goku
demonstrates the ability to deal damage
on the monster without so much as
transforming or opening his eyes instead
deciding to share that he can read
yakan's movements using the air currents
that he's walking within and even beyond
that he trivializes the darkness with
the life produced by his Super Saiyan
form of course there is still one
wrinkle left in this fight
though it initially seems to be yet
another Beatdown this fight hides within
a lot of subtle setup narratively with
Goku instructed not to turn Super Saiyan
as yakon eats light energy he chooses
instead to Double Down turning super
saiyan and then filling him to the brim
at the last moment turning super saiyan
2. not only is this Goku imposing his
clever nature once again but this single
approach unfolds a lot to come in that
single action we not only learned that
Goku and Vegeta have achieved the form
previously held only by Gohan but have
also planted a seed for Vegeta himself
in that moment as Goku showcased his
true strength though his reaction is
reserved the seeds have been planted for
Vegeta's upcoming midlife crisis he saw
the results of Goku's afterlife training
and no doubt felt the truth that Goku is
noticeably stronger than even he
Gohan vs dabra this is babidi at his
most desperate but his doubts are
quelled once the capable and
level-headed dabra enters the chamber
now fighting Son Gohan confirmed to be
as strong as perfect cell was during his
last battle with Son Gohan dabra proves
to be an interesting measuring stick
with which to compare Gohan's current
level against his previous outing and it
seems Vegeta's criticisms towards Gohan
at the very beginning of this Arc have
been warranted he lacked a desire and
will to keep training during peacetime
and now is facing a threat the likes of
which he shouldn't be struggling against
gosh doesn't that sound familiar but
what makes this fight interesting isn't
the fight really but more so what it
draws out of the other characters
exposing Gohan as the character that out
of the three fights we've seen he's the
only one who found difficulty and
moreover this roadblock brought about by
his own complacency now eating into
Goku's time left on Earth is starting to
similarly eat away at the same Prince's
patience or so it would seem for now
leading to Vegeta's Outburst that gives
way to a Sinister idea in dabra's mind
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this reveal is what the stakes of the
Ark really established themselves as be
greatest threat present was dabra a foe
who we know for a fact could be easily
defeated by half of our combatants but
now the dynamic has shifted one half of
those top tier Fighters has now swapped
sides and as was established with
spokovic he received a significant boost
in power how this is all presented
leading up to it is a very careful
orchestration however though it seems
simple on initial viewing Vegeta just
losing his patience and Bobby taking
advantage of that with the hindsight of
Where The Story Goes later on it's
pretty clear what Toriyama had in mind
from the get-go from the moment Vegeta
sees Goku power up against Yak on his
entire demeanor ships while Gohan holds
his own against dabra Vegeta's outbursts
are not subtle or nuanced they are
pretty loud and pointed moments for what
we later Learned was a meditated attempt
to get papadi's attention the Saiyan
Prince saw the depths of Goku's strength
and realized instantly that he was out
matched the very last time Vegeta saw
Goku fight was at a very different
period of his own life one where he
rejected the idea of sentiment and told
himself that he cared not for anything
other than his own hunger for power and
status and looking on as Goku
demonstrates that he not only ascended
far beyond where he himself once stood
but he also pushed himself harder and
farther than Vegeta ever thought
possible at that moment Vegeta felt
tremendously ashamed ashamed to have
left the gap between the two of them
grow so wide and that familiar feeling
he once had staring at cockrod in all of
his golden Glory reignites that same
selfish urge within Vegeta that was long
thought to be extinguished now branching
an M for the Majin on his forehead it
acts as a visual marker that proves to
be both Skin Deep physically and as is
later revealed metaphorically so also
on their heads that is the mark of the
Majin if babidi finds any evil in your
heart he can use it to control you
turning you into his puppet oh wait any
evil yes any evil even using your phone
during a movie or leaving your shopping
cart in a parking space Oh that's super
evil the card return is like right there
hello can I speak with a Vegeta [__] are
you name's Bobby son of bibbity that's
stupid right well I'm here to make you a
proposition I'm listening oh hold on
what about tipping because some places
actually pay their employees but others
don't I mean obviously then you tip at
the places that don't this is why I hunt
my own food come on Vegeta
see it's deep in your soul let me give
you what you want all the power that you
need to defeat Goku
you know
funny thing is
I know you're playing me
no don't tell me that Vegeta has
darkness in his heart
[Music]
[Applause]
following this rather significant moment
for Vegeta there is a brief cut away
back to the tournament showing us Videl
arrived back told Goten and Trunks
what's going on thus spurring them on to
join the action with the Warlock but
more importantly the conclusion which
saw the re-crowning of Mr Satan as the
world champion and moments following
this uplifting and somewhat humorous
moment from Mr Satan and Android 18. as
an audience we're greeted with one of
the most difficult to believe scenes in
all the ark
[Music]
laughs
this is a tough scene for a number of
reasons one because naturally it sets in
motion a series of events that Define
this Arc and the scars it leaves two
because we know what it means for a
character like Vegeta and those he loves
looking on to Bear witness to and
finally the third reason I find this
scene rather difficult to get through
because in some ways even when I take
into consideration the broader message
of the story and Arc of the character at
this point in Vegeta's story this feels
almost a step too far which I accept is
the point of this scene after all Vegeta
knows he needs to cross a line to get
the reaction from Kakarot he desires but
in saying that I do have some thoughts
broadly speaking this is a necessary and
phenomenal portion of Vegeta's character
Arc one that shines as a favorite from
many Vegeta fans what initially began as
a slow but observable change in the
Frieza Saga eventually Rams up to a
significant change in the South Saga and
is now at a point of no return in boo
slowly over the course of this story
Vegeta has changed for the better
rejecting his egotistical and lonely
ways for a life where he has begun to
embrace those values of family and peace
he once previously so harshly rejected
and this shift in his character can be
observed not just emotionally and
narratively but it is also observable in
his physical appearance in the story
character design is very important and
no character better represents that idea
in Dragon Ball than Vegeta first
introduced during the Saiyan Invasion he
wore the latest and most ostentatious
armor from the Frieza Force head to toe
large shoulder pads bright blue jumpsuit
this was Vegeta at his most cruel and
lost
following on from that in the freezer
material Vegeta arrives on Namek in the
same outfit however he is pretending to
be the same Vegeta who was once allies
with Frieza and during his time spent
Dynamic this facade gets chipped away
slowly almost as if it represents his
one solid alliance with Frieza now left
in tatters for all to see wanting
nothing more to do with him instead
going into business for himself and this
all comes to a head during his battle
with the Ginyu Force where there's very
little left of that original armor
forcing him to in the second half of
that material to shed his old look and
begin donning a much more understated
and muted tone the maniacal and
bloodthirsty Vegeta isn't the same as he
once was no more flamboyant shoulder
pads or bright colors he's rocking an
older model of the armor trying to get
the job done a job he ultimately can't
finish with the very armor he wore then
acting as the suit with which he would
be buried in continuing on the story had
very different plans for Vegeta forced
to wear civilian clothes now and
eventually armor designed by Bulma this
is the first time Vegeta flirts with the
sight of good fittingly doing so while
wearing Earthling attire which finally
brings us to the boo Saga in the seven
years during the time skip having gone
from being a broken Saiyan following the
death of cell it's clear that Vegeta
found meaning in another area of his
life finding a reason to March onwards a
reason to keep fighting one has to
remember the last line of dialogue
Vegeta offers following the defeat of
cell was that he would never fight again
however the first line of dialogue he
has in this Arc is to Gohan reminding
him that training is important to keep
up in peace times nestled into that
friendly piece of advice to Gohan is the
suggestion that Vegeta found something
to fight for he found a reason to pick
himself back up from the pits of Despair
during the time skip in other words he
found something to fight for and
moreover train for
because now he has something he values
protecting this is the most domesticated
and well-adjusted we've ever seen Vegeta
and this is reflected once again in the
clothes he decides to wear during this
material no longer wearing any armor of
any kind instead choosing to wear a
loose fitted fabric not massively
dissimilar to the material other
fighters on Earth are wearing
communicating to us that not only is he
comfortable on earth now but unlike any
other period in this Arc Vegeta's own
emotional guard is further down than at
any other point in his life in this
first half we see that he cares about
his family and friends he trusts those
he has become familiar with and in the
grand scheme of this story this piece of
visual storytelling is nothing short of
spectacularly done intentional or
otherwise however while these subtle and
explicit developments in Vegeta's
character are evident for all of us to
see and while Vegeta's sudden and
violent relapse feels both reasonable
and compelling on the story front it's
this degree of severity he lashes out
with at the Tenkaichi Budokai that feels
almost out of character for this moment
to slaughter hundreds of people in front
of what he knew to be both his friends
his wife and even his son though
thankfully he wasn't there at this point
this feels incomprehensibly Thoughtless
and self-indulgent particularly for a
character whose entire story in this
material is about him facing the fact
that he has changed and does actually
love his family
stop it jigs this isn't like you you're
not a bad guy since when
when on this worthless uh should I ever
become a quote unquote good job you're a
krillin's barbecue last week yeah and I
brought potato salad he has truly lost
to us wait no you mustn't this fight
will only serve the haste of Majin Buu's
Awakening and how strong is he much
stronger than any of you no I mean he
can literally blow up galaxies
Mr Shin you are only making this worse
[__] mortys
ignoring my minor tonal issues with this
particular section it should be stated
that these present circumstances and
actions taken by Vegeta really helps to
put everything into perspective in this
story everything that felt strange in
this Arc everything from the lack of
Direction in the narrative early on and
the strange opening round selection
between him and Goku to the bizarre
off-beat atmosphere that began to color
the gauntlet it appears as though
everything else up until now has been an
annoying distraction to Vegeta or so he
claims murdering hundreds at the
tournament to emphasize the scale of the
destruction it's an intensely powerful
scene that's brimming with subtext
colored by each character involved sure
we have what is effectively Vegeta's
relapse or midlife crisis in full swing
but this also exposes some of the most
compelling character moments Goku enjoys
in the series understanding what this
situation is in ways neither Vegeta nor
the Supreme Kai can fully accept or
understand this is an exceptionally
serious ghost Goku that has only one
request to utter to be transported to
where they can hurt no more people in
addition to this story concerning itself
with the themes of fostering the Next
Generation there are plenty of
additional elements exploring the
resolutions to unresolved issues that
reside in the past a culmination of
choices come in Full Circle the very
poison that colored Goku's character at
the end of the Saiyan Saga begging
Krillin not to kill Vegeta because he
wanted so feverishly to one day to fight
him again has yielded a series of
consequences Goku himself is responsible
for and that only he can resolve one
that resulted in the callous deaths of
hundreds an event that anyone could have
foreseen happening back at the end of
that fabled confrontation and so it's
for good reason that Goku is so serious
on this occasion in more ways than one
he asked for this and now he has to pay
for it on the other side of the coin
Vegeta is dealing with his own
complicated set of circumstances after
selling his soul to this proverbial
devil he now finds himself in bed with
he's on a collision course with his arch
rival but additionally in his own mind
too represented by Bobby in this case
Vegeta is fighting a battle on two
fronts one with the foe he so
desperately wants to best in the real
world and another fight in his mind
against the evil wizard poverty over who
he truly answers to and according to
Vegeta he answers to no one but himself
in a fight that was all but destined to
take place no matter the obstacles no
matter the moral Quagmire no matter the
magic involved Vegeta needs to fight
Goku and where better for this legendary
match to take place then the wastelands
Where it All Began
[Music]
I don't understand why would you let
Bobby do this
you don't get it how could you you who's
never once questioned why he fights
you've always lived for yourself train
for yourself
once you are gone
I lost what drove me to be better I lost
my Edge and now I'm going to PCA
meetings at krillin's movie Nights
listen to me kakarovsk I'm using his
[__] name but now I have a chance the
chance to finally fight you one on one
no Outsiders no interference just you me
a live victory
why
that's it yeah look geez I'm just here
for the fight you don't gotta justify it
God I missed you
interestingly and perhaps surprisingly
to those of you that have only watched
the anime this fight isn't afforded the
same emphasis or spectacle in the manga
while the Grandeur of the fight in the
anime is an absolute treat much of the
fight in the manga is actually off
screen though not all of it pertain to
the manga are the elements that boil
down to what is effectively the true
meaning of this fight not the actual
blows the fighters trade but the words
they speak amidst it all you see while
this fight is exceptionally cathartic
and exciting to see unfold the context
it operates within is what ultimately
changes our feelings towards it outside
of boasts in the same fighters in a very
similar location this fight isn't
anything like the original and that
difference is made all the more apparent
as the fight and Vegeta's thoughts
unfold a near tragic fight between two
Rivals it's clear how avoidable this all
would have been if not for Vegeta's
crisis of Faith so to speak and what's
more 4 is it's remarkable how much of
this Arc feels as though it's been
intentionally tied to the events that
have defined two generations of the sun
family events that feel intentionally
mirrored to convey and color the tone of
this story and toy with our expectations
as viewers where the original story saw
Goku stand in defense of the earth
against a great threat one that saw him
along with the efforts of all of his
friends and family unite to protect
themselves against the great evil one
that saw them struggle to gather the
strength necessary to save themselves
comparatively this fight we see before
us feels like a total vanity trip and
ego driven Enterprise that only serves
to create negative consequences for
those that need to and will pay for it
it's been demonstrated to us that they
already have the power they already have
the means to change the course of
history but they don't have the will
instead they are all caught up in either
the consequences of their own past
actions or their inability to move on
from them and so the net effect of this
battle taking place can only be negative
but it's so much worse than anyone even
Bobby could have predicted in mere
moments following the fight's
commencement Vegeta and Goku's entirely
selfish side quest has bore fruit that
only served to remove the final nail
from Boo's proverbial coffin
foreign
's reveal is the biggest visual
subversion a villain has ever been
presented to us with in this series and
by all accounts we should most
definitely have seen this coming no
other villain in the history of Dragon
Ball has received so much buildup dread
or story leading up to their eventual
unveiling Frieza probably comes the
closest but even then he still doesn't
begin to approach that of Boo's
introduction for Frieza despite getting
similarly terrifying forewarning was
very quickly revealed to us unlike Boo
ever since Shin made his surprise debut
in this series we have been building up
to in one way or another this Grand
unveiling there's been suspense drama
swerves a gauntlet match and a host of
other elements that have all assembled
together for the sole purpose of
building to this one Monumental moment
and that moment plops out and starts
dancing and stretching like a cartoon
character and it makes sense like I've
said in this video already this Arc
feels like Toriyama at his most
unbroiled it reads sometimes similar
like his old super gag-centric material
early on with fourth wall breaks and
crazy dialogue heck he even at times
took the change in the narration text
boxes in this Arc text boxes that one
time in the past denoha toriyama's own
internal Voice Now chime in to present
Gohan's voice instead almost to reflect
the superhero comic book type Vibe he
was going for this is all to say that
this Arc is built differently naturally
the nature of Majin Buu state gets
expanded upon later but you can't deny
the impact of this unveiling having
spent a considerable amount of time in a
rather serious atmosphere all building
to this pivotal occasion Boo looks and
acts utterly disarming and well
ridiculous but that's the point and it's
where all of the terror he offers the
story stems from early on the contrast
of his appearance against the reality of
his actions even the way he looks right
now said alongside Shin's dialogue is
almost comical it's too late we can
never Escape now Shin explains while Buu
is dancing and seen goofing around in
the background like a fat genie
finally after all these years and all of
my hard work he's finally been set free
my baby boy
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry does he need to go back in the
oven I'm on a clone so I don't really
remember the original Deborah little
help here let me talk with him Master
Majin Buu
you new friend you play games with Bill
I am not here for games I Am The Demon
King Deborah our Master is poverty and
you shall follow his every whim
understood you play games with boo what
was that speak up you pillowy pink
premium
[Music]
[Applause]
oh God
following this even Shin the god amongst
Gods admits to making a foolish mistake
in underestimating the sheer strength
and ability of these mortals living on
Earth he reveals to Gohan that had he
known of their ability he could have
gone about things differently and I
think there is a very good reason shin
and Gohan are paired together for so
much of this arc's early material they
largely exist as parallels of one
another both exalted individuals who
have a lot expected of them for one
reason or another and yet have entered
this situation woefully underprepared
had either one of them approached this
with the requisite knowledge or
Preparation it is almost certain that
these events could have been avoided and
in Shin's case he never even considered
for a moment that there existed anyone
he could meaningfully consider an
opponent to babady's forces any possible
way to combat this impending outcome but
via pure cunning and trickery but he was
wrong and by the time he came to know
this it was all too late
foreign
[Music]
ravages both Gohan and shin in what can
only be described as a childlike chaotic
Outburst under no circumstances could
this be considered anything other than
an out of control monster now and it's
the speed of the forcefulness of these
fights that really sells Boo for the
terror that he is in just two Choice
attacks he's completely knocked out
Gohan with his life having been saved by
Shin at the last possible moment Gohan
has been reduced to a dire State not
really seen since Goku after his fight
with Ginyu arguably worse at
circumstance so brave that it even grabs
the attention of two Saiyans on a date
with Destiny Goku and Vegeta despite
being the rematch to end all rematches
once again Toriyama subverts are
collective expectations what was once
the greatest and most inspirational
matchup in all of Dragon Ball has been
reduced to this not even the main focus
of the arcs material instead a Side
Story which selfishly facilitates the
chaos that ensues and what's more is the
a story we are shown time and again is
that through it all not only does Vegeta
still not have the advantage in this
fight he gave up everything to have but
Goku just continuously calls out this
tantrum this relapse for what it is just
a crisis after all the Bloodshed after
all Vegeta's Bluster and damage levied
onto Goku during this battle Goku just
doesn't buy it and with the fight now at
a complete standstill all of this talk
from Goku the new key in the distance
clearly formidable and Gohan's key
having just vanished entirely it's
enough to force Vegeta to realize that
he isn't going to get what he wants here
he's not going to get the triumphant
rematch that he wanted because in more
ways than one that ship has a long since
sailed and now having unloaded all of
this baggage he has to pay for the sins
he's committed
[Music]
wait
watch
Philip
yeah you're strong I dropped wanna go
see
yeah I do hey see I do know you shut up
and give me a sensu baby you got it best
buddy feel bad we couldn't finish her
fight though I didn't even get a chance
to whip out my new
foreign
meanwhile while all of this Terror has
taken place almost poetically Goten and
Trunks representing the generation that
will inherit the problems and sins of
the past are none the wiser to all that
has transpired discovering once having
arrived on the scene of Majin Buu's
release if you familiar looking statues
the chilling remains of their friends
and they break Piccolo
meanwhile dabra starts to clash with boo
it's monster what it is he can see past
all of its disarming Fanfare and it's
here Akira Toriyama utilizes one of his
favorite techniques to give readers
their first Glimpse at how powerful boo
truly is prior to this during the
spaceship Gauntlet we learned that dabra
is on par with perfect cell and yet here
even when armed with the element of
surprise and a literal piece of Weaponry
he is nothing compared to boo it's a
simple technique to establish Stakes
based on prior content and Toriyama
loves to do this it's one of the reasons
Mecca Frieza exists to be cut down in
the previous Arc for example and so now
we have it clearly defined that Majin
Buu is unlike anything we've come across
in this series an entity that makes
perfect cells seem like literal Child's
Play and with new Stakes established
this unfocused and childlike force of
nature runs rampant with regard for
nobody but his own child like whims it's
all for his own satisfy action and
amusement
master I beseech you look at this thing
it cannot be trusted or controlled it is
not a child yes Deborah he is a child a
child that must be nurtured and raised
into a subservient obedience little
Deborah
where did you go
[Applause]
wow mantel is going to be really pissed
at me who gives a [__] [__] is barely
Cannon
well at least in the face of this
overwhelming and unsettling show of
force Boos scene to the unstonifying of
both Krillin and
wait Piccolo
he regenerated yeah okay I guess he
regenerated well then that's surprising
I mean I guess we never established how
much namekians can regenerate before and
I mean then those cell regenerating
using namekian cells but
yo
and this my friends is the beginning of
the end and for Vegeta this is the last
thing he will ever see and I think now
is as good as time as any to say that I
love this incarnation of Majin Buu's
design the angry face the dumb Cape the
Big Belt the steam puffing out of his
head when it's mad this is one of the
most fun designs in the entire series
it's utterly spectacular and you can
tell Akira Toriyama is having so much
fun with it and did a collection of
guidebooks released after the manga was
complete Toriyama saw fit to share some
of his preliminary sketches for this boo
design some are better than others but
man am I happy he landed on this and on
this fan favorite occasion I don't think
Vegeta could have asked for a better
dance partner to bounce off of both
literally and figuratively everything
about Boo screams unthreatening blimp
and as he fights with Vegeta arguably
the most serious character in the series
as the fight starts it almost seems like
Vegeta might stand a Fighting Chance
seven years of training at his back as
well as a significant power boost from
Bobby's magic he spends half of this
chapter attacking boo even going so far
as to combo him into a trunk-sized hole
in his chest the entire fight has a very
eerie vibe to it though as he's tossed
and spun around while boo performs
bizarre and Goofy move after bizarre and
Goofy move and despite being filled with
the resolve he's never once before
boasted despite Piccolo even reaffirming
to us that at this very moment in time
Vegeta is stronger than both Gohan and
perfect cell War at the end of The Last
Arc it doesn't take long before the gulf
in their power becomes apparent even
Vegeta's most devastating blow is
described as hurting quote a little and
little is enough to send boo into an
explosion that renders Vegeta into a
state remarkably similar to that of
Gohan at the end of the cell Saga and
from here it's only a few pages before
boo wraps Vegeta into his own goo and
begins to beat him senselessly Vegeta
has seen a lot of brutal beatdowns over
the years but there's a distinct
hopelessness to this one with each
subsequent blow Vegeta is bloodier and
bloodier leaving him lying completely
incapacitated and defenseless a faith
just as bad as gohans with this Vegeta
has lost the result of all his selfish
crisis and endless conniving deals with
the devil for power all of it is exactly
the same outcome as the fate of the boy
he mocked for his complacency earlier in
the end despite a powerful showing
against Majin Buu initially all of his
actions led him not to his own
satisfaction and exaltation but to his
bloodied face in the dirt thankfully
much the same way Goku found himself
saved from Vegeta long ago thanks to his
friends and family by his side so too
does Vegeta now have family and loved
ones that can look out for him his seven
years of Peace were whether he realizes
it or not has garnered him not only a
son that deeply cares for him but
friends around him that would watch by
in desperation as his life is in danger
but there is a difference here a key
difference Vegeta has had people by his
side before hell Future Trunks spent his
entire existence in the cell Arc doing
his best to support and impress his
father Vegeta standing by his side to
the very end and when the cards were on
the table for future Trunks sing the
writing in the wall for Vegeta as he
faced off against perfect cell in vain
he ultimately didn't have the courage to
make the save before Vegeta was downed I
mean how could he the last time he tried
to do that it only made his relationship
with Vegeta worse so instead for cell he
chose to wait until Vegeta was on
death's door knocked unconscious and out
of his Super Saiyan state but here
against Majin Buu things are different
the trunks of the present does doesn't
spend even a single moment contemplating
what he should do the second the cards
are on the table for Vegeta trunk
Springs into action flying in
desperately at top speed and Landing a
remarkably effective kick against Boo
and once Vegeta is unraveled and brought
back to Consciousness how does he react
not with the usual callousness and Scorn
that we have come to expect from him in
Prior arcs no berating no boasting and
overcompensating for his defeat instead
Vegeta looks off for a moment deep in
thought and comes to terms with the
consequences of his actions telling his
son to look after his mother
at this very moment Vegeta's long
winding Evolution as a character has
come to its conclusion at the end of it
all through hardship victories
humiliations and mountains of selfish
errors in judgment we finally see Vegeta
at the end of his journey a Vegeta that
has come to terms with who he is the
values that he has for so long scorned
and then acceptance of the unbridled
danger he is directly and purposely
Unleashed against the universe
against the ones that he cares for with
Majin Buu out of the picture for a brief
moment every second Vegeta spends in his
final moments reveals to us what matters
most to him as a character
first bite hugging his son trunks
something he admitted to never doing
when he was a baby it's something that
you never in a million years would have
expected to see even at the end of the
cell Saga but in this moment his only
son is his number one priority and after
his final goodbye he albeit in a very
Vegeta way tends to him as well as Goten
and makes sure that they are kept safe
with the boys taken care of handed over
to Piccolo who has single-handedly cut
poverty down quite literally in the
meantime there's a quiet moment shared
between both he and the Saiyan Prince
one that again draws comparisons to
Vegeta's past one that's colored by the
fear and Humanity that's always been a
part of his character for as long as we
can remember this quiet somber
discussion between the two illuminates
the other thing Vegeta cares for in his
final moments after ensuring those he
loves will be safe and you see Vegeta's
died once before in this series
disillusioned bloodied and beaten on
Namek he looked on crying and begging
for Kakarot to do what he simply could
not against the Tyrant Frieza a man that
enslaved his race killed his family and
people and forced him into demeaning
subjugation for his entire life it's a
moment that encapsulates the Despair and
shame he must have felt after living a
life holding all of those emotions in
it's one of the most powerful scenes of
Vegeta's character has ever participated
in but after it had passed after having
confessed everything alone in the dark
dressed in the attire of his oppressor
Vegeta died knowing that he wasn't
enough full of regret fear and sorrow
buried by the man he despised but in
this scene this circumstance it's
different and he knows it fearful of
what he's about to do he asks Piccolo if
he'll see Kakarot in other world the
subtext is clear however Vegeta wants to
know if he will have an afterlife to
himself at all if he will get to fight
on after or if his soul will be cleansed
and reincarnated forever lost he all but
knows the answer to this question but
the fact he asks it at all speaks to
what he must be feeling at this time
he's searching for something positive to
latch onto in this terrifying storm of
circumstance but Piccolo answers
honestly with a resounding no explaining
that he has led a life so full of death
and resentment that he will most
definitely meet his end right here and
now if he goes through with what he has
planned there will be no more his story
will end here and faced with that
reality as physical manifestation of his
own sins and marches towards him he
orders Piccolo to get both himself and
the two boys as far away from here as he
can even with irreversible death and
reincarnation awaiting him Vegeta
marches forward knowing he must meet his
fate Vegeta more than anyone else has
made this mess and it is clear that
anything else to him that he has to
clean up that mess anyway at any cost
not for himself but for those he now
realizes he cares for and what follows
is a scene so dense with complex emotion
that I think it is likely unmatched in
the series past and present a saying
that millions of people across the world
recognize as the defining climax of
Vegeta's character in this story one
that puts a pin in the long and winding
Arc he's undergone since first setting
foot on planet Earth during the Saiyan
Saga a scene that has remained in the
hearts and minds of fans for decades now
this moment is not only Vegeta's last
Bastion the final member of the eldest
generation ensuring that the Torches
pass to those below him but an act of
courageous desperation the mess Vegeta
has made is all but insurmountable and
he knows if he doesn't manage to take
care of it somehow his actions will be
the end of everyone he knows and so with
nowhere left to turn no other option at
a disposal Vegeta faces his most
desperate act not with fear this time
but with his trademark smile on his face
there was nowhere he seeks to run no
training left to do no power-up left to
surmount this foe no comrades left to
rescue him no complications left to
arise
there is only one thing left
[Music]
okay
you may have invaded my mind and my body
but there's one thing a Saiyan always
keeps his pride
[Music]
[Applause]
a warrior vanishes in a distant blinding
light
his name was Vegeta the proud Saiyan
Prince
and there you have it that's Vegeta's
sacrifice and part one of this
comprehensive review of the boo Arc
as being an Illuminating Journey one
that I've enjoyed far more than I
thought I would in two weeks time we
will be dropping the final part of this
series and with it the remaining Dragon
Ball Z abridged Clips concerning what's
left of the story but until then I've
been totally not Mark and thank you so
much for watching
trunks
I am going to hug you for the first time
ever
oh cool
hug complete
is it okay
I'm a way better Dad than Kakarot
namakian take the caca tot and my son
away from here fine I've got nothing
better to do and this is way above my
pay grade but before you go
tell me
you think I'll see Kakarot when I die
what like in heaven because
no okay [__] you but fair
hey we're not done playing with you
squinty eyes on me Bubble Yum we're
playing my game now first rule you
[__] die oh boo has played this game
that regeneration [__] got old six years
ago so I'm gonna take a page out of
kakarot's book
I'm gonna hit you really hard
enough to wipe every last bit of you
from existence
[Music]
this is farewell
Bulma
Trunks
and even you best buddy
Vegeta now a cheetah
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign